hey everybody I'm Lucy unwelcomed up to
the gamespot stage here at e3 2015 I'm
so excited I can barely get my words out
because joining me here today is Lina
senior producer dice on kind of the big
splash one of the many big splashes but
certainly the big / cause it's coming
this year star wars battlefront you know
how are you finding III this is your
first III you're telling me this is my
first III and I'm finding it uh no quite
spectacular to be honest I mean you
can't you can't go and I the hall
without seeing Star Wars and I was here
this morning when the the hordes run in
and they went straight for Battlefront
what's that kind of reaction like
especially like as developers to see
something you've labored over being
loved like that I think I mean obviously
I theis we are so with such fans of Star
Wars and we have were so proud to be
have been given this opportunity to work
on this game and we've you know poured
our hearts and souls into this project
for a long time and we've been so
longing for the opportunity and the day
to actually give others the opportunity
to play it and the reaction that we've
had so far with both of the the
multiplayer trailer but also the the
missions trailer and and you know how
people have seen the game how people
have been playing the game and unhappy
people seem to be to me it's it's
amazing and I just wish my entire team
was here that they would be able to see
and and feel what I'm feeling right now
but it's been absolutely amazing let's
talk a little bit about how the
opportunity came about did you guys have
to lobby for battlefront didier just
kind of throw it open to all the studios
and say hey we've got this really big
franchise that people coming to love who
wants it he wants Tibbs I think that for
us you know we obviously I mean we're
building to you know you know we're
known for building battlefield then and
you know we're building mirror such and
as a studio when the opportunity arose
we were in you know how thought working
development from PF for we were
delivering me research
and but when we heard that the franchise
was up for grabs so to speak that II I
had had you know struck a deal with this
name was going to bring you know Star
Wars experiences to gamers and in you
know through various Frances's going
forward you know we were kind of the
obvious choice i think i think that you
know people understand that the battle
fronts but front one bathroom too they
were you know in many ways spiritually
related to BuzzFeed and so it kind of
was a place to the case of the franchise
coming home so to speak yes in that
sense so so but we you know kind of put
our hands out there and said hey hey
guys we should do it yeah and we could
then we got to make it then and that's a
then a pretty amazing experience so far
so it was announced back in 2013 we saw
we heard we saw the first trailer really
last year and then we had a little bit
more star wars celebration and now we
have actual gameplay this is the
survival I believe no this is the
multiplayer on multiplayer yeah um and
people are getting their hands on it now
yes because it's not long until it's out
which is a great thing yep so how are
you I mean what you're deciding what to
show is this what encapsulates your star
wars I think that you know what this
shows is that you know it hits on the
note what we wanted to do with the game
is what we wanted to immerse players in
their star wars battle fantasies and
this mode walk your ass off this the
sort of the quintessential mode in the
sense it so it's a big mode it's 40
players it's infantry its vehicles its
workers it starfighters its heroes it's
you know all of the all of the
ingredients you know in its most epic
sense so in that way we want it and it's
on half obviously the mode is inspired
by the Battle of Hoth yes and so that's
kind of what we wanted to show that you
know we wanted to show yes we're super
true to the you know the visuals and and
the original trilogy but we're you know
there's a twist you know you get to play
it your way you get to do things that
you know aren't strictly true to what
happened in the movie
atra so we you know we first thought
would be a great experience to bring to
to III was that in a way more freeing
than kind of making an experience that
was just you replicating what we've seen
in the movies and it kind of it allows
for player freedom I guess yeah and i
think you know freedom is so incredibly
important in games and I think you know
various types of games have various
restrictions you know on the design and
the experience but I think that you know
yes you want to be you know you want to
be immersed in the universe that you
know and love and that's why we're
bringing you to enter and we're bringing
you to hof and will bring you to
Tatooine but we're also bringing the
vehicles I mean we're seeing an 80 80 on
Tatooine as an example which you've
never seen before which you will see in
organic cannon bending yeah I guess in a
way or it's it's more about sort of you
know giving you all of the in Crete five
million ingredients in a way yes and
allowing you then to make out of them
what you will how you know play the game
your way have the experience that you
want you want to take on you know you
know do you want to take on Bobo fast as
Luke Skywalker you can do that yeah mr
Grey parrot cheats it's right now we saw
in the VA press conference Luke
Skywalker just walking right up to Darth
Vader at a moment that could only really
be possible in the middle of a big
battlefield a moment that could only be
possible in a kind of video game and it
allows you to freedom do that yep uh so
let's talk a little bit about you know
the legacy of the original games um was
it kind of a pressure to keep that like
I mean those games were incredibly
popular I mean both critically and
commercially you know so was there a
pressure to kind of keep it very very
similar oh you guys desperate to you
know put your own mark on on Star Wars
which is a rare thing for anyone to be
able to do well i think you know we you
know the original games were great and
they were as you said incredibly popular
and beloved and you know by many of our
developers as well and
think but the fact of the matter is that
they were games that were out to console
generations ago so that long already
yeah it is that moment read Ian and of
course I mean gaming as a whole and the
genre as a whole has evolved since then
so we first but you know the right way
to respect the franchise was to sort of
you know we I think we're in many ways
many ways keeping the the spirit of it
and you know to the spirit of what made
battlefront great and we're nothing to
it in many ways but we also said to
ourselves we're going to do it the way
that we want to do so obviously
battlefield is kind of your bread and
butter what have you what experiences
you taken from that game and kind of
poured into battle front yes but week is
our our heritage applies and I think
what's great for us is that we have a
team that's a mixture of battlefield
veteran developers and the developers
like myself that I've never worked in a
battlefield game so we have a mix of of
people and I think we take from part of
it I mean IIIi don't think people would
argue that dice is you know is the
master off of you know epic scale and
vehicular gameplay and you know
obviously that that fits so well with
what we're doing here but at the same
time you know there are other aspects of
battle fig that you know we've kind of
help us to say it we've kind of taken
you know some of the aspects of what
made possible great and and you know
added them into our game and then we've
you know come in a very different
direction on other aspects of it and I
think that's a part of the sort of we
want battlefront to be its own thing
have its you only unique ID and and be
you know its own unique experience but
of course there's a lot that people will
recognize I mean I think you know in a
way it Isis is a premier developer of of
FPS shoot there's an obviously we bring
such a great amount of experience and
knowledge yes to the game so let's talk
a little bit our fan service I mean just
being able to pilot an 80 80 being able
to pilot the Millennium
welcome we played players Boba Fett luke
skywalker darth vader i mean with those
moments that you guys I mean did you
have to decide by committee because
there is so much to take from Star Wars
how did you decide which great bits to
put in well I wouldn't say that we've
designed it by committee because we have
a very strong very competent design lead
but we believe you know basically what
we've taken is sort of what to us is the
core of Star Wars and I think you know
Star Wars is so vast there are so many
things in Star Wars but you know our
beloved by so many and you know so that
there are hard choices but I you know we
kind of selected what we first was the
absolute core of Star Wars and people
can then debate that endlessly whether
you know this is more core than that or
or you know why do you have this and not
this and you know and and put it we
can't do everything yeah unfortunately
so suddenly people where we're kind of
upset at the lack of a single player
mode yep but then again you guys do have
single by content yes but I think one
thing you should really be celebrated
for is offline split screen oh ah let's
talk a little bit about that because
that for me is really exciting because
I'm still a person who loves to not have
to bring another TV into the room to be
able to play co-op yeah yes absolutely I
mean that we are you know battlefront is
predominantly a multiplayer game but
with the star wars battlefront missions
our ambition is to give players a great
on porting experience in playing what we
call the trial missions which are
teaching you to you know master
different aspects of the game but then
we have what we call the survival
missions and the survival missions all
of the missions you can play either by
yourself or you know throw online co-op
or split screen co-op on consoles but
the sort of you know the survival
mission as an example what to show that
the sony press conference yesterday and
when which is playable at the sony booth
here at e3 is this is where you
basically either by yourself or with a
friend take on
waves of Imperial soldiers that they're
also supported by a TS TS & Tie Fighters
and and so we wanted we really really
wanted you to be able to just jump in
and play say you're sitting you know on
a Saturday night with your friends
around the house and you kind of just
want to have that experience you know
that split screen in spirit that was
super important to us it's something
that's kind of very missing from modern
gaming I find especially in first-person
students I mean you know you want to be
able to sit with your friend let's talk
a little bit as well because we can
split between first and third person
which is really a big part of the
original yellow front and that's an
example I think of sort of how we you
know not towards the you know the the
original trilogy and the same with our
game of design I mean we've taken no
game mode wholesale but of course we've
been influenced by the original games I
mean how could we not and that's I mean
I think that you know that this is one
of the features of the original the
original games that players love then we
were really happy to make that call to
be able to play in third person as well
and I think you know people talk about
instant action was a beloved mode and
why we don't have instant action in the
exact same way the the intent with the
survival mission as an example is to
give you that same experience of being
able to play against AI you know jump in
and play against AI in an in a really
deep and satisfying way yes so I'm let's
talk a little bit as well about the fact
that you guys using photogrammetry yes
which so games always been made in
frostbite 3 so it looks it looks great
but photogrammetry for me is also
incredibly interesting how have you
managed to utilize like to make the game
we have I think we've gone to uh you
know we've we've been more extreme and
using photogrammetry than I think any
other game with have you know we have an
absolutely amazing art team yeah that's
their super super hardcore Star Wars
fans and and you know for them it's been
a dream project yes to work on so what
we've done is that we've gone to the
original locations where the movies were
shot to capture trees and rocks and snow
and
you know all of the district natural
elements to bring them back into the
game but we've also gone to the the
archives the Lucasfilm archives at
Skywalker Ranch that was a terribly
terribly hard trip that I needed to make
you know I had to take one for the team
and go there oh no yes just have to go
over this guy yes no I mean it's it's
one of the incredible incredible
benefits of working on a project like
this is to get to do things like that
it's it's absolutely amazing and and the
photogrammetry is basically what we you
know there's a technology where you take
whether it's a natural object or a
man-made object such as you know imagine
if you will a lightsaber or Darth
Vader's helmet and you take a bunch of
pictures from slightly different angles
all around and then you stitch these
images together using software so that
you end up with a 3d model that you can
then refine which then in in essence
means that you're bringing the real
objects into the game world it's kind of
fasting as well I mean because Star Wars
and you need that authenticity because
there are so many passionate fans from
the 70s when the movies first came out
and you guys sound like you're doing it
right like you're going the right way
about it and we're super excited to play
it please tell the lovely audience when
it's out when we get our hands on it and
which platforms it's out november
seventeenth on xbox one ps4 and PC Lina
thank you so much for joining me friends
I'm afraid that is the end of day one
here at e3 2015 we have had some amazing
games on the stage today join me Danny
O'Dwyer Chris waters tomorrow because
I'm not going to spoil it all here but
we've got some amazing stuff coming up
so make sure you tune back in tomorrow
gamespot com we'll see you then
you